the UK is unquestionably facing an
unemployment crisis for the latest
figures suggest that for now the wave of
mass redundancies is being held in check
the headline unemployment figure between
March and May was 3.9 percent that's
unchanged from the previous three months
but that's because employment is still
being propped up by the Treasury nine
point four million employees are on the
job furlough Scheme and another 2.7
million self-employed workers have
received payments now many of their jobs
may no longer exist when this support is
withdrawn beginning next month but
there's evidence the labor market is
already crumbling six hundred and forty
nine thousand people left company
payrolls in the three months that June
though they're not all yet formally
considered unemployed and the claimant
count that's those seeking universal
credit or job seekers allowance has
increased by 1.4 million since March
that's up to 2.6 million in total and
the number of vacancies is down by 497
thousand on this time last year that is
a record full the Chancellor of the
Exchequer knows he has a problem the
figures today show that our furlough
scheme has been effective at protecting
millions of people from unemployment but
I understand that people are anxious
which is why last week we outlined our
plan for jobs across the country we will
be able to protect support and create
jobs
these figures don't necessarily account
for the daily toll of a redundancy
announcements that we've heard from some
of the highest profile employers in
British business Sky News has been
tracking these since the outbreak began
and our analysis shows that at least a
thousand job losses have been signaled
every day since lockdown began we can
take it look at some of the worst hit
sectors starting with aviation UK
companies have signaled more than 30,000
job losses with the largest number of
British Airways which is making 12,000
redundancies and what about hospitality
where almost three million workers are
under threat so far more than 12,000
redundancies have been formally signaled
including 5,000 an upper-crust owner SSP
we've also heard peter express his
to close 75 sites placing hundreds more
jobs risk
the collective impact of these losses is
forecast to leave more than three or
perhaps four million people out of work
addressing that will be a defining
challenge of the pandemic